on the mound for the marlins it's
braxton garrett second major league
start when his major league debut
trey turner will be the lead off guy
again garrett is into the wind-up first
pitch to trey turner swung on and
hit in the air to left field and moving
back to deep left center
on this one and looking up is joyce and
this one is gone goodbye
and the nationals lead one pitch into
the game
one to nothing two one nobody out three
balls and two strikes here's the pitch
swinging a little looper over the first
baseman's head up base it down the right
field lie
soto scores from third rounding third is
cabrera
he's coming home heading for second is
suzuki and it's the nationals three
and the marlins nothing ben bramer he's
from baton rouge
not far from andrew stevenson's backyard
18th rounder by the nash four years ago
out of sec country auburn and now the
set of the pitch
in there called strike with a breaking
ball at 75 miles an hour and cooper
is the second out caught looking at
strike three
now the pitch swinging he pops it up
right field toward the line taylor
coming
in into his left into foul ground now
reaching back to his right
for the catch that retires the side a
walk in a man left after one in game two
that's three marlins nothing
three defenders left side for the right
hand batting michael taylor hitting 203.
that is strike three so the
second strike out of the afternoon for
braxton garrett
and a base hit to right juan soto's
fifth hit
of the series trey turner stops at
second here's the 2-1
and the ball is sent in the air to right
going back deep
is brynson he's on the track right in
front of the mikazuki sign and he makes
the catch
cabrera is out number three on the long
fly ball we're in the middle of the
second
and the nationals have a three to
nothing lead on the marlin suzuki lead
off the third inning for the nationals
who lead game two of the doubleheader
three to nothing
pitch up and kurt suzuki up to left
c u later and kurt suzuki has driven in
three of the nationals four that's his
second of the year
michael a taylor on a pitch in the dirt
struck out first time
here's a swing and a drive well hit to
left for taylor back in deep left center
it's going going and long gone
michael taylor with another home run for
the nationals his fifth of the year a
two run shot
and the nats now lead it six to nothing
here in the third so here's the
left-handed hitting
shortstop jazz chisholm the 2-2 to
chisholm
right in their strike three call that
was a knee-high
center cut fastball here's a fly ball to
right field shallow toward the line
taylor racing into foul ground he's
going to get there and makes the catch
to end the inning sabrina pitches around
the two out walk
marlins lead one josh harrison who's
walked and ran into anderson
harrison drives one up the middle soto
home
it's an rbi single for josh harrison and
the nationals lead at seven to nothing
here in the fourth inning
harrison picks up his 11th rbi kibum
right-handed batter against knight at
the right-handed pitcher and a shot back
up the middle behind second birdie has
it races to the second base bag
and he gets there just ahead of harrison
to end the inning
nicely done by john bertie harrison's
out four unassisted
and that'll do it look at brian anderson
to the plate swinging a miss
and down goes anderson on strikes now
you are down the right field line that
will fall
fair taylor cuts it off and he'll get it
in
that is the first hit for the marvels
set the 2-1
curveball is popped in the air to right
center taylor
drifting over and now in a few steps
waiting for it he makes the catch
and brain were able to finish off the
fourth inning two down
trey turner to the plate trey one for
two three one on the way to turner
swinging a line drive base hit right
field that'll score
nol from third and turner picks up his
second rbi of the day
and it's an eight nothing nationals lead
and the nationals have two in scoring
position
3-1 is blasted deep right center field
this one is way back going going and
long gone into the second deck
a three-run homer has drooled cabrera
the nationals pouring it on
lead 11-nothing here in the fifth and
it'll be the man that he's failed to
retire yet john bertie's faced him twice
and walked him twice
2-2 pitch is in there strike three
called locked him up with a change up
and ben bramer if that's it finishes
with a flourish his fourth strikeout and
he is qualified to
pick up his first big league win with
five one hit
shutout innings victor robles up three
ground ball out
and robles turns on one deep left
see you later it's now washington
13 and miami nothing here's the pitch
swing by stevenson in a fly ball deep
right center field
marty back way back is harrison he can't
get it
it's off his glove and off the wall and
the nationals with back to back doubles
and on to their lead with three runs
home pitched to cabrera swung on line
drive right field another base hit
that's down and toward the line rounding
third is stevenson will come in to score
but it's now the nationals 15 of the
marlins nothing